freunde was geht herzlich willkommen zu
diesem heutigen videos ist wie ihr seht
ein bisschen anders ein bisschen
besonders ich bin gerade im auto meiner
mama unterwegs ich bin ja auch zu hause
bei meiner familie in aschaffenburg und
vielleicht wissen dass manche von euch
andere bestimmt auch nicht auch ruft
kommt aus aschaffenburg und gestern wenn
ich das aufnehme war muttertag sorry
wenn dieses ding da unten nervt das kann
ich leider nicht besser lösen jetzt
gerade gestern war muttertag und auch
toni war zu hause bei ihrer familie und
deshalb dachte ich mir wenn die mal
nicht auf madeira ist haben sie bestens
kennen gelernt auch persönlich hole ich
sie mal ab wie schnecken was neues
zeigen euch ein bisschen was unsere
heimatstadt so zu bieten hat das durch
sie glaube ich eine ganz lustige nummer
wir haben wir holen sie jetzt erstmal ab
so antonia das jetzt auch zugestehen und
unser erster stopp ist bubble tea du
warst glaube ich noch nie bei einem food
video so richtig dabei hast du schon wie
freddy was gedreht
wir haben uns überlegt was wir machen
können beziehungsweise ich habe schon
überlegt und ich dachte halt so futur
erstes problem ist es montag ich habe
meine mutter gefragt montag hat fast
alles ich kenne das gar nicht nur aus
köln ich glaube das ist in vielen da
gibt es da so sonntags mit auch hat auch
alles auf das ist schon sehr sehr nahe
ist muss man sagen
aber ja wir sind als erstes ein bubble
tea ich habe gerade schon toni meine
party story erzählt das war für mich so
ein ding lange schule nachmittags
unterricht und dann hat so ein
mitschüler von mir immer für alle bubble
tea geholt das auf jeden fall ihren
durst sagt das 25 jahr nicht gefunden
ich hasse
zumindestens tatsächlich crazy ich habe
auf jeden fall richtig bock drauf und
toni wird dann nach dem besten burger
den besten döner aus erschossen
jetzt gerade ich finde wirklich döner in
aschaffenburg sind sehr sehr nah bin ich
auch also köln und ich habe letztens zum
beispiel was von manga gegessen der
bünder land von lukas podolski
der ist eigentlich richtig gut gerankt
so platz sechs in deutschland trotzdem
fast jeder der in aschaffenburg ist
geiler also ich lieb dass hier
irgendwelche noch wissen wir überlegen
ob wir zudem gehen wo ich vorgeschlagen
oder nämlich ein bisschen traurig nicht
zu dem auf jeden fall futtern wir uns
jetzt ein bisschen durch du bist jetzt
angekommen
ja aber irgendwie fanny ich habe auch
super viele die einfach zu bekommen
ich hatte was von aschaffenburg dann
kommen so dann kommen so die erschaffen
begrüßt die grenzen im umkreis quer ja
genau genau
ich komme zwar nicht aus aschaffenburg
aber aus kleinostheim tattoo machen
lassen
oh ja ja den
ein smiley unten aber nur ich bin nicht
dumm auch nach ist was ich so krass für
den aschaffenburger ich weiß nicht was
fühlst manchester gesprochen
irgendwie habe ich immer so als solcher
ist schon schön so ja ich halte diesen
job der stadt geht ja ja das haben wir
in diesen chats blick drauf los
ich bin doch ich habe dieses ganze
dieses dass man so übereinander lästert
und soll sich ab checkt das habe ich
einfach das klingt jetzt komisch das
habe ich einfach gibt es lange nicht
wahrgenommen so ich habe irgendwann erst
mal gecheckt auch kraß machen leute
leisten weil ich war so vorher blauäugig
und ich meine ich ja auch gut so ich
meine wenn du mit der einstellung durchs
leben geht danach fragt sich auch nicht
ab aber wir haben auch dann irgendwann
leute gesagt so als ich mit meinen
youtube videos angefangen und so finden
dass die leute nicht komisch aber keine
ahnung vom pisco bischwind kann ja sein
aber irgendwie ich weiß aber was du
meinst also es wird es wird schon so
viel viel getan hat sich für dich
irgendetwas verändert seit er nur
getoppt ist mit streaming und soll in
aschaffenburg
ich war sehr verwundert darüber dass
leute an bahnhöfen warten
was hast du gesagt hast dass du gekommen
und was bekommen aber und auch in berlin
auch also an den ganzen
die leute standen gegen diese aus
stuttgart und so ich find's nicht ins
ried ich habe schon überrascht darüber
wie viele leute checken auch dass das so
eine once in a lifetime nummer ist weil
wir wieder auf aber greift das gekettet
das habe ich lange nicht gehört sowas
das kann ich nur von den alten youtube
zeit da waren die leute auch sehr
motiviert aber vielleicht sind ist jetzt
so streaming ja als ich hier noch
gewohnt habe ja stimmt ja das wasser
würde mir ein foto tripp ist so funny
reihe ich damals gerade mit youtube
angefangen habe mit minecraft video
höher und ich kann noch gar kein von den
touren so ob ich sie nicht endlich der
suchenden aber sie gerade angefangen und
das war so für mich im moment verwirrt
wieso ist ja jemand der so diesem
eingriff videos macht die ich auch
machen zu dem zeitpunkt ja ihn
erschaffen wurde ich erinnere mich
leider nicht mehr an diesen ein bisschen
tagen im moment aber das war also
wirklich hört sich sehr fangen jetzt
schon bei unserem ersten stopp ich hoffe
das hilft gerade überlegen ob das der
ist wo ich früher im ja genau hier vorne
ich glaube dann ist das der horror
nights dann hast du deinen wenigstens
bei meinem gibt es nicht mehr
das crazy war das ja nicht sterben so
ein verbot mit diesem babelsberg das hat
man immer gehört dass hat man immer
gehört ich glaube aber das hat mich
nicht so vom staat war es hier für die
verboten babbel tee zu trinken
die erste sache die bubble tea es um das
sehen und so antonia bubble tea sie sind
direkt fünf jahre jünger welche möchte
lieber an du hast die frei weil das
mango milch mit mango babbel vier sich
mit erdwärme
ich möchte diese entscheidung
offentliche abhalten
da kommen wir machen es wirklich lange
her auch dass ich angefangen ich habe in
köln das mal an einem mit getrunken
meine mama hast du sonst ausmacht wir
müssen alles heute bewerten ich bin sehr
gespannt wie sich das einordnen
ich glaube bei babbel ganz ähnlich viel
richtig oder falsch
hallo leute diese uci hart kommt
vor genau fünf jahren profi ist das auch
eine portion oder 719 ist wie es gestern
war das war irgendwie es hat mich
irritiert so ist also zu schnell zu heiß
da haben wir ein paar wichtige kauft man
durch den park da eine grüne laufen zur
schule
wenn man so eine freistunde immer der
weg city-galerie was ja hinten homberg
ja okay bei mir ich war ja eine andere
ecke für mich war immer die challenge in
den 45 minuten mittagspause schnell mit
dem fahrrad weil jeder auf seinem
fahrrad bekommt mit dem fahrrad zum
burger king hält und wieder zurück man
kann also locker fünf stunden über
chancen gut dass man hier alles so
früher gemacht habe
ich denke selbst wenn wir nicht genau
dieselben act kommen diese spots diese
also beim kommt oder soja
was mich aber gefragt hat wirst du den
next level pokal mit nach madrid nehmen
aber wo ist denn jetzt gerade die haben
doch geklaut oder einfach in stuttgart
gerade bei genug kinder mitgenommen weil
dieser von ihrem hotelzimmer im autohaus
ich keine mitnehmen
hätten sie sich noch mal nach berlin
schleppen müssen wenn ich jetzt nach
stuttgart geht dann denke ich dass mir
schicken
wir haben in den wichtigsten faktor drop
aschaffenburg münnerstadt
es gibt nur in berlin bessere döner
finde ich habe ja okay ich habe einmal
mit sehr viel zeit mein papa hat schon
seitdem ich klein war jede zweite woche
in berlin gelebt und dann war ich auch
viel in berlin
ich habe mir mal mit meinem bruder zeit
wollen wir haben richtig so denn
natürlich ab krasse und wir hatten so
ein laden so döner 44 heißt ja glaube
ich in berlin kreuzberg und das ist
nicht nur so eine ladenzeile so ein
meter fünfzig und da steht so ein typ
vorne und er sagt den ganzen tag ist als
ob man salat haben will und der dann
hast du krank bist so könnte es auch
doppelt so groß wie normal
trotzdem muss auch endlich romantisieren
jetzt hier nicht so krass wie zum
beispiel so ein mann der so sagt er mir
irgendwie vorstellen dass das denken
monte der ist ja so wie bist du der
hometown heroes also der das steht ja
krass verboten wurde und er feiert er
sagt er bei allem was ist das beste das
kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
ich muss aber auch gucken dass man
irgendwie auch
[Musik]
dann habe ich halt irgendwie 34 jahre
mein eigenes ding so gemacht dass ich
habe mir während der schule gut
angefangen und ich fand das lustigste
was war videos auf die neun minuten 59
zu machen und keine werbung anzupassen
ich habe damals auf jedes video zu einer
funktion news corp ich habe keine
werbung kein cent für die das paar
monate 30 euro oder so irgendwie
höchstens für die mit so keine ahnung 5
millionen user gratis verlost 5
millionen der weiße 50 fand so lustig
weil man keine mit rot schalten konnten
ich war ja weil ich halt keine werbung
und wann hast du so gesagt so youtube
ist aber so kritsch ist wir haben oft
mit youtube weil es einfach mit stressig
war und nerviges thema für mich und dann
habe ich halt dann wieder angefangen als
sie mal lehrer will und dann habe ich da
ich meinen fokus auf streaming gelegen
fast du bist quasi sie aufgebaut
genau also du hattest wie lange hat so
gar nichts gemacht
zwischenzeitig so einem jahr alle sechs
monate sieben monaten suchen also ein
video von wegen also wenn ich eine sache
kenne von youtube-videos dann sind die
leute tut mir leid jetzt kommen wieder
häufiger videos ja das ist das habe ich
so peinlich oft gemacht dass ich mich
irgendwann als ich das einmal so
ausgestellt ist jetzt nicht rein das ist
er wieder in familien habe ich einfach
mal angefangen habe es richtig macht
soll wir über treppen zum bildern wo
leute was ich toll sogar kurz mal mein
handy raus und film ab für euch es ist
das heftigste ich habe letztes darüber
nachgedacht und für mich ist es glaube
ich euch die knoblauch so
und seien wir haben beide kein sitzt ja
noch ein bisschen in diesem auto guckt
euch das einfach mal es ist wirklich
dieses brot ist auch so anders irgendwie
ich kann euch nicht sagen ich freue mich
richtig drauf weil das ist lange her
dass ich denke also dass narren feiern
durch das war's das war ja nicht selten
weil es hier nicht so super vier geht an
so einen dienstag wurden trotzdem bock
hast was du unternehmen ist auch schon
vorgekommen dass ich damit kumpels im
dönerladen gesetzt haben so
schlappeseppel getrunken hat das bier
von hier und das ist das ding ist ich
glaube es ist ein angelernter geschmack
ich war mit meinen jungs mal hier in
erschaffene und die kommen ja alle
versuche die zum großen teil aus köln
und wir haben den döner gegessen und ich
war so mein gott versteht was meine und
die war also entweder wollten die mir
nicht können in dem moment das ich dass
ich gesagt habe jetzt rast oder ist ist
für die apa nicht so heftig aber für
mich ist dass mich der beste trainer
vielleicht noch ein bisschen diese
erinnerung an partynacht mit leicht
angetrunken zu diesem geheimen gehen um
der so bist keine ahnung man offen hatte
immer diese töne der dann immer als
unnormal geschmeckt hat die pommes
lassen auch geil
ja ich frage mich aber ob döner
besorgten besser schmeckt normalerweise
schmeckt man ja aber so wenig wie so
manche sachen sind so einfach von brand
und so massiv sein wird als in vielen
kalorien und fett soll die prämien es
ist für mich wirklich wohl sagen denn
neun von zehn döner bei zehn prozent ist
die salaten in berlin und diese
erinnerung ist aber auch sechs jahre alt
war für eine stunde gesperrt werden
machst du jetzt mehr so
[Musik]
im format wird nämlich mal gesehen ein
tag persönlicher kochen
darüber hat sich das alles voll auf
seine focus entwickelt
ja irgendwie schon ein ja also ja ich
habe einfach mit tatsächlich gedacht hab
so gut ich mache gerne leuten so eine
freude durch kopf für leute fakt ist
auch in videoform 8 haben mir dann
überlegt und dadurch habe ich so diese
credibility bekommen dass leute so war
es jetzt auch sehen wollen überhaupt
leisten
das wetter lädt fans auffällig ich bin
jetzt halt möglichst einfach die ganze
zeit nur noch keines essen
der würde man also kann mir keiner
erzählen dass es nicht ein ganz anderer
ist als das was man können ist es mein
holy grail wirklich mal den ball bei
persönlicher koch bei meinem format ja
ich habe schon einiges versucht wird ich
habe ein komplettes video ihm gewidmet
und ich habe mir für das video märz von
ihm gestellt habe in den ersten zehn
sekunden habe ich schon sagte jörg czech
den merch store
ich hasse komplett ihm gegönnt aber er
ist nicht interessiert bin ich mir
ziemlich sicher ich habe auch einen
gemeinsamen kollegen so gesagt ja auch
wenn es irgendwie klappt so ich würde
nach wien wird morgen nach wien fliegen
oder aber ich glaube da hat einfach
keinen bock auf diesen youtube film
leute eine stunde später unfassbar gut
gesetzt fühle mich gut war mit chillige
zeit
ich bringe jetzt antonia wieder nach
hause es war möchte das muss bleiben im
video
mein gedanke war einfach nur so
aschaffenburg antonias auch hier
schaffen die ich gebraucht hatte
jaja damit ich sagen sehen wir uns im
nächsten video wieder
ich fahre heute abend schon wieder nach
köln die nächste woche noch mal lehrer
und danke das zusehen bisschen nicht
nochmals getaucht